I hope you liked it that was my
monologue thank you very very me take
you now to Andy's rebuttal to Colin's
monologue
good evening I'm Andy Richter the state
of Conan's monologue is passively
inconsistent
oh sure Conan's monologue may have his
core supporters laughing the two hundred
people here in the studio but what about
the millions of Americans at home not
laughing or the billions around the
world looking on in horror mr. O'Brien
just do the monologue jokes stop wasting
the audience's time with string dances
nipple touches and bad
Adebayor it's cheap time-wasting fluff
and it doesn't sit well with
hard-working folks like Denise from San
Bernardino Denise is a preschool teacher
and a firefighter a homemaker a waitress
and a registered nurse and she served
three tours of duty in Afghanistan yes
she doesn't have a lot of free time for
mindless [ __ ] on behalf of everyone
here Jess and now
Conan's rebuttal to Andy's rebuttal
hello I'm counting to Brian I just want
to remind everyone that Annie Richter
hasn't paid attention to my monologue in
over ten years
you see he's too busy getting drunk and
popping pills and kissing up to me
isn't that right Annie yeah that's a
that's a good one boss yeah god Bless
America god bless the country god bless
the nation and God bless the United
States of America
you
you